the refugee crisis created by the war in
ukraine has come to america's doorstep
hundreds of ukrainians are gathering in
mexico near the u.s mexico border with
many waiting at an encampment in tijuana
just south of san diego now the biden
administration has promised to welcome
100 000 ukrainian refugees into this
country but that involves a process
manual jorquez is in tijuana for us
manny good morning so you've got this
big number of refugees legally being
allowed into the country but you've got
all these others waiting there at the
border why are they trying to enter from
that location why are they going there
well good morning tony as for the
ukrainians it's because they can obtain
a visa to travel here to mexico as
tourists and then they make their way to
this busy port the port of san ysidro
volunteers who have been helping them
say about 150 ukrainians a day are being
allowed into the united states on a
humanitarian basis and more are coming
just a thousand feet from the u.s border
and more than six thousand miles from
home
ukrainians fleeing war eat and sleep on
the streets of tijuana this is your home
for the next few days yeah that's all
what they can bring with me anastasia
bettu's parents stayed behind you have
hope that it will get better there
hope and the pray
hope and pray
others here stay at hotels but come back
to check their number the number
assigned to them by ukrainian american
volunteers
that determine when they can present
themselves to u.s border agents what
number are you my number one 11585
this is where the encampment started
it's a bus station the last bus station
before reaching the u.s border and just
days ago it was only a few dozen people
here but it has grown exponentially it's
now estimated there are more than a
thousand ukrainians waiting in this
general area it's the same place where
asylum seekers largely from latin
america and the caribbean have
previously gathered too but most have
been turned away due to current u.s
immigration policies
at this shelter they tell us they feel
for the ukrainians but say they're also
facing life and death situations like
roxanna ruiz ramirez from honduras who
says gangs are threatening to kill her
family
you need help too
for now more ukrainians are coming
volunteers greet them at the juanes
airport
next one and a gym is being turned into
a shelter
back at the border
god bless ukraine god bless mexico and
god bless america
a woman named mila from los angeles met
her 17-year-old grandson who traveled
alone for almost a month from keith he's
very very happy that he's here on this
length and you know can be united with
his family
russians are arriving here too about 800
in february the month the war started
they say they're anti-war and fleeing
political persecution but their cases
are more complicated because the u.s has
not created an official exemption for
asylum seekers from russia gail
manuel thank you so many people in need